my questions later senator start your
blog and a regular books and I'm all
giving back but I also work full time
yeah this order to have an advice to
have a scale to give my assets to fight
it out that's where I'm making my own
hair down and eventually yes I wanna do
my blog all-time teach people how to
network but how do I get with massive
book by putting in the time and it's the
only ask that you got right right like
that's your asset like you know and you
know this if you read the books I'm
obsessed with this notion of 7:00 p.m.
to 2:00 in the morning like you know you
know listen I complain every day like
rock man they need to be swayed and like
this that method I yell at like my new
assistant Mike I'm like you got us
together
the truth is I'm not putting in the work
I had time like when I tell everybody
that they can sleep one hour less if
they want to build a business
I can sleep one hour or less to hit the
gym right so you know it's what you put
in man like you you know what I like
about this though is work takes up a lot
of time and energy but when you're
actually doing something you love it's a
little bit easier to put in that 10 p.m.
11 p.m.
listen bunch of us I see a couple of
guys here at vaynermedia we're in the
office the other day - 2 o'clock in the
mornings the 131 it's the latest I've
been there line because we night at 1:30
in the morning we were working on my
brand for the first time in a long time
because the book is coming and guess
what I love my brand you know I love me
and I was easy I wasn't tired I didn't
want to go to sleep and so you know the
thing that I would tell you to do that
gives you the best prayer for this to
lurk is make sure you really in tune
self aware that this blog is around the
thing that you like the most you know
don't make it about interviewing
internet peeps like unless that's the
thing you won't unless you grew up one
day I want to be Charlie Rose unless
that's right
but you know one day you wanted to like
ride dinosaurs made it about [ __ ]
dinosaurs